foreign
Jacob is up next in Saginaw Michigan hey
Jacob welcome to the show
hello how are you doing we are doing
well thanks for the call how can we help
uh so my wife and I are in more debt
than I ever thought I'd be in and we are
struggling with going forward with this
and wanting to grow our family
all right so tell me a little bit about
the the debt situation how much do you
guys owe
around 200 000. okay what type of debt
is it
uh uh 175 000 of it is in student loans
okay and then we have uh my wife's car
and some credit card
and then some money that we owe my
wife's parents okay so how much is all
that how much is the car
uh the car is 14 500. okay credit cards
seven thousand and how much you guys oh
the in-laws
twenty seven hundred twenty seven
hundred okay how much you guys make a
year
together eighty four thousand okay
and do you guys have do you guys have
kids now or you're wanting to start a
family what were you what's part of that
wanting to start family okay how old are
you guys
we were both 27 27 that's great
um well I want Jade to jump in here
because
um
she and her husband walked a really
powerful story but Jacob I also want to
tell you just hearing you
and your voice
um you sounds overwhelmed and tired
stressed maybe even a little embarrassed
and shameful like I just want to
encourage you that as you guys begin
this journey
your future is so bright you guys are
young you have time you have ability and
what you guys have done in the past and
even though it feels so overwhelming and
so stressful I'm just telling you doing
this job for over a decade
this can change and that's the really
beautiful thing about this Jacob is that
you guys have the ability to and so Jade
what would you what kind of
encouragement would you give Jacob as
they as they start this because it feels
like a lot I you know I Echo what Rachel
said you guys have time and this does
feel overwhelming I mean I'm not gonna
lie it's a lot of debt but it doesn't
mean it can't be cleaned up and I know
that you can go you guys can work this
plan and also you know your income's
going to go up you're 27 years old your
income's going to go up and when it
comes to the family side of things if
you're looking to start a family like
Rachel said earlier do it you know you
don't have to wait until you're debt
free you know to start a family so I
kind of want to just like give you the
the go ahead on that and when it comes
to this debt like let's just work this
out okay so are you just a listener or
have you had time to dive into the baby
steps or Total Money Makeover or have
you just learned about us through the
show here on the radio
podcast uh a co-worker told me about the
show in November and I've been listening
to the podcast and reading some books
that I got for Christmas okay that's a
great place to start before you get off
the call today we're going to make sure
that you and your wife get Financial
Peace University because that's going to
be what's really going to hammer home
everything that we talk about on the air
today you're not going to remember
everything yes you can go back and
listen to it but Financial Peace is
going to really go through this with you
guys and get you on the same page and
give you that hope that you need
surrounding your situation but for the
time being let me kind of just walk you
through this so that you've got some
hope when you get off the phone here
with us today so we're just going to
boil this down into the easiest possible
step easiest baby step going forward so
do you guys have any money set aside in
savings whatsoever
uh we have a thousand dollars excellent
so you got baby step one accomplished
check one very good and now after that
we're talking about paying off debt and
baby step two using the debt snowball
but before I get into that are you guys
using a budget because you're gonna need
to be on a budget in order for this to
be effective
yeah we've been working through a budget
the last month and a half or so uh-huh
are you using every dollar or just
something else
uh there's spreadsheets that I make okay
that's totally fine okay so with your
budget how much are you able to after
you've just paid minimum payments on all
of your expenses after you've crunched
everything down right because we want to
decrease lifestyle as much as possible
how much do you have to throw out your
debt
each month right now we have 1100 okay
so we're gonna just start with that 1100
and we're going to start with the
smallest possible debt um it looks like
the the family loan 2700 So you're going
to be able to knock out a good portion
of that
um you know a third of that this month
and then you're just going to keep
working down now the thing with the debt
snowball is like you're listing them
from smallest to largest I know you've
got student loans and you're probably
thinking about interest rates I know
they're on pause right now but listing
the debts from smallest lar to largest
paying minimum payments on everything
and all the extra money that you can
find you're putting at that smallest
debt now here's the thing I want you
guys working because you can only you
can only lower your expenses so much
right you got to get your income up more
too and it doesn't have to be long term
it can be temporary but we gotta get out
of debt when my husband and I were
getting out of debt we paid off 460 000
of debt Jacob and we had our regular
jobs but we were moving Heaven and Earth
to get as much money in our monthly
budget as possible I'm talking about
training dogs and selling cupcakes and
and putting tint on Windows these are
the things that we were doing to make
money and here's the thing you don't
have kids yet and while you don't have
kids that's when you can get out and
really get get your hands dirty I mean
this is this is the time of life yeah
you can be working until two and three
in the morning you don't have to worry
about a baby screaming so please please
please take advantage of this and I'm
not saying don't start a family but I'm
saying you got nine months at least
that's right that's right you know what
I'm saying so Jacob it's about hey you
know it's about how quickly you're gonna
move this needle so and we talk about
gazelle intensity Jacob and you'll hear
that in Financial Peace when when you go
through it with your wife
but there's the the the the mindset of
getting into debt is pretty easy right
you sign your name to some paper you're
kind of just falling in and it's just
you kind of we say you can wander your
way in but you cannot wander your way
out and so we talk about gazelle
intensity because in Scripture it says
if you have signed Surety my son do this
deliver yourself like a bird from the
hand of the flower and a gazelle from
the hands of the Hunter and so that
gazelle when you have that picture of
the Discovery Channel and watching a
gazelle outrun a cheetah the intensity
The Strain running for their life that's
the amount of intensity Jacob that I
want you and your wife to be in because
you're not going to knock out this debt
and it's I know it's overwhelming it
feels like a lot of you know two hundred
thousand dollars but you guys can do
this yes you really can't but it's gonna
take a it's gonna take a lifestyle that
people are gonna make fun of you you're
gonna you're not gonna do anything
you're really gonna put all of your
money towards this debt you're going to
be working extra like Jade said it's
going to be a season of sacrifice but
it's just for it's for a period of time
and then after right Jade that's right
Sam you're like oh when it's all done
you're like okay look when when the
storm clouds finally part you guys are
gonna be doing a happy dance like nobody
else you live like no one else now and
that means you know an old busted car it
means selling things it means working
hard but later you're gonna be able to
live and give like no one else you're
gonna change your life you're going to
change your family tree and that change
starts today Jacob changes a choice you
can do this dude